on ne peut pas être contre la vertu on
est en faveur de s'assurer que les
paradis fiscaux ne soient pas utilisés
par les canadiens on doit travailler
avec les autorités nécessaires pour
s'assurer qu'on est en train de
s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de tricher je
tiens à féliciter brigitte alepin la
cinéaste québécoise qui a fait du bon
travail en mettant ça devant tout le
monde dans son film le prix à payer
aussi il ya le brunch thaksin est conclu
qu'il y avait des milliers de milliards
cachés monsieurr peuvent rien faire
c'est son monde à lui moi je vais
m'assurer qu'on va aller chercher cet
argent là parce que chaque fois qu'on
laisse échapper cet argent noir au fisc
c'est la classe moyenne qui finit par
pâturer et puis encore plus de taxes
nous on va aller le chercher cet argent
merci monsieur je sais c'était un des
principaux convoite le bloc a mené au
cours d un côté paradis fiscaux et à ce
moment là c'était les libéraux qui
étaient au pouvoir continuer à le mener
sur monsieur atteint et moi je pense
qu'il faut s'attaquer en premier lieu
aux banques canadiennes qui ont beaucoup
de filiales dans ces paradis fiscaux il
revoir chacun des traités que le canada
avec des paradis fiscaux sans moi je
pense est essentielle à faire et on a
tous les pouvoirs le fédéral a tous les
pouvoirs pour agir de la sorte
merci monsieur madame mais oui merci il
y à plus de 170 milliards de dollars
d'argent partis ont une vision fiscale
et on doit le retrouver
c'est un scandale que nous avons les
quatre l'argent dont les paradis fiscal
c'est clair que les impôts
cet essentiel ici au canada pas dont les
parts des détails mais ne pensait que
nous favorisons la réduction des taxes
et des impôts mais cet essentiel que les
russes que les grandes compagnies paient
leur juste part et dans chaque de nos
péchés il ya des étapes des milliards de
dollars pour retourner pour éliminer ces
paradis fiscaux et on a en a signé une
entente on en conclure l'entente avec
nos partenaires du g7 pour poursuivre
ses objectifs